usually one of the top financial
priorities for us average people is to
get out of debt whether that be student
loans car loans or a mortgage we want to
pay them off as soon as possible to
minimize the interest we pay if we had
the money most of us would avoid debt
altogether but ironically some of the
richest people in the world also have
the most debt in the world by now i'm
sure all of you guys have heard about
elon's plan to take over twitter for 44
billion dollars and given that elon's
net worth is currently hovering at about
a quarter trillion dollars it's not
impossible for him to just pay cash yet
he's planning on taking out quite a bit
of debt the current plan is to take out
13 billion in debt against twitter and
12.5 billion debt against his tesla
stake this means that he's taking out a
total of 25.5 billion dollars in debt
now elon may choose to pay more cash by
the time the deal closes in order to
minimize the risk of a margin call but
the root question still stands why even
deal with the debt and the banks and
interest payments when you don't have to
this doesn't just apply to large
purchases like twitter either many
billionaires will take out debt to buy
homes yachts and private jets even
though these purchases are a miniscule
portion of their net worths elon himself
had five mortgages totaling 61 million
dollars before he decided to sell all of
his houses and move to texas
so why do billionaires voluntarily take
out so much debt
one of the main reasons which
individuals prefer to take out debt
instead of just paying cash is to
maximize their returns given that
they're already rich they're well aware
of how to produce significant returns on
their money whether that be investing in
commercial real estate investing in
stocks or putting it all towards another
business these guys are experts at
consistently beating the market take
tesla for example since they went public
in 2010 the stock has grown from four
dollars and fifteen cents to eight
hundred and seventy dollars today
this comes out to an impressive 200x
return in 12 years or an annual rate of
return of 54.5 percent
and that's just the returns that tesla
has produced as a public company usually
the majority of gains are made before
companies go public so for it to make
financial sense for elon to sell his
tesla stock and let's say by twitter
twitter would have to reliably produce
more than 54.5 percent per year
now of course tesla isn't going to grow
at this rate forever but i think you get
the point twitter would have to
consistently beat tesla's annual return
for it to be a worthwhile investment and
the truth is this is not very likely
first of all it doesn't seem like elon
is even buying twitter to make money it
looks like he's buying it for social
reasons and to hopefully create a change
that we want to be just very reluctant
to delete things just just be very
cautious with permanent bands and a good
sign as to whether there is free speech
is someone you
don't like allowed to say something you
don't like so while twitter may
naturally grow to 100 billion dollars
under elon's leadership it's not likely
that it becomes like facebook and
reaches a trillion dollar market cap or
anything so from elon's perspective it
makes sense to minimize the capital that
he does tie up with twitter given that
it's just a side project the same
principle applies to much smaller
purchases as well
for example let's go back to elon 61
million dollar mortgage which took place
in early 2019. at the time tesla was
just starting to recover from production
hell and nearly going bankrupt and
shortly after elon took out these
mortgages tesla stock actually plummeted
to just 36 dollars per share in june of
2019.
now imagine if elon decided to sell 61
million worth of tesla stock to pay for
his properties instead of taking out a
mortgage since this low in 2019 tesla
stock has grown nearly 23x meaning that
that 61 million dollars would not be
worth 1.403 billion dollars even if we
assume that the property is appreciated
to 100 million dollars elon would have
left 1.3 billion on the table and that's
not even including future growth this
argument becomes even more relevant when
you're talking about depreciating assets
like a private jet or a yacht such
purchases are basically guaranteed to
lose 70 to 80 of their value if you own
them for a long period of time so it
makes no sense to pay for these
purchases upfront the only reason you
would pay for them upfront is some sort
of peace of mind but in terms of returns
taking out debt is absolutely the way to
go
aside from trying to maximize returns
one of the key reasons billionaires take
out debt is because they have no choice
while they may have tens of billions or
hundreds of billions on paper the vast
majority of this is simply paper weld
and completely illiquid for example over
the past week elon sold 8.4 billion
worth of tesla stock to raise the cash
that he committed to put up for twitter
this sale itself caused tesla stock to
fall 12 in a single day
imagine if elon had to sell five times
that amount to raise the full cash
required to buy twitter by the time he
was done selling tesla would likely be
down 60 to 70 percent if not more aside
from plummeting the shares of his own
company he would have to deal with so
much backlash from tesla shareholders
many tesla shareholders are already
pissed off that elon sold tesla stock to
buy twitter to many of them twitter not
only seems like an unfavorable exchange
but it also seems like an unnecessary
distraction and they haven't been scared
to hold back their thoughts either this
one twitter user posted i don't like
that you sold shares elon your money is
not the last one out i know people who
got margin called today not cool this
other user tweeted i'm more disappointed
he used it to buy twitter genuine
question how many more years does
twitter have and all of this was just
for a 12 sell off elon would literally
be burnt alive if he cost a stock to
sell off sixty or seventy percent and
this is the same case with other
founders as well
bill gates for example had to spend 25
years to cash out of his microsoft
position
at least these guys have the option to
sell if they really want to
many smaller billionaires don't have a
choice due to stock vesting company
owners usually don't want high level
executives or employees to sell off a
bunch of stock if the company is going
through a rough spot these guys selling
would just cause the stock to dip even
further and leave the company off in a
worse position so most companies
implement a policy called stock testing
that prevents employees from selling
their stock for a set period of time
google and apple for instance follow a
four-year vesting schedule
so when you see headlines like
sunderpiche made 281 million last year
or tim cook made 265 million last year
just know that while this is technically
true they won't actually have access to
this money for years to come
the only money they have access to
instantly is their cash compensation
which for cinderkitchee is quote on
quote only 650 thousand dollars so while
someone like sunder or timmy can
comfortably afford a 20 or 30 million
mansion on paper they don't actually
have the cash upfront which forces them
to take a mortgage
while maximizing returns and liquidity
are significant considerations something
that we haven't even talked about is
taxes but really this wouldn't even make
a difference because these guys
implement several clever strategies to
minimize taxes one of them being taking
out debt while they will have to pay
three or five percent interest on their
loans they can avoid much more on taxes
currently the highest tax bracket for
long-term capital gains is 20
and if you live in california like many
of these billionaires do you'll also
have to deal with state income taxes and
to make things worse california does not
discern between capital gains and
regular income so you'll have to pay the
full 13.3 percent to california this
means that your total tax load comes out
to 33.3 percent now i'm not looking to
argue it if this is a fair amount or not
but this strongly discourages
billionaires from selling their stock
going back to elon 61 million dollar
mortgage we already calculated that elon
would have left 1.3 billion on the table
if he paid for these properties in cash
but this doesn't even include taxes if
we tack on a 33.3 tax we'll see that
elon would have had to sell 91.5 million
worth of stock to pay for these
properties in cash and given that tesla
stock has grown 23x since elon bought
these properties that 91.5 million
dollars is worth 2.1 billion dollars
today meaning that elon would have
straight up left two billion dollars on
the table and looking forward if tesla
grows another 5x within the next 10 to
20 years that 91.5 million purchase
which was a minuscule portion of elon's
wealth even in 2019 would be worth 10
billion dollars so when you have
exponential growth working in your favor
you want to be as invested as possible
and you definitely do not want to bleed
any money to the irs
while everything we've covered so far
are great reasons to take out debt even
if none of these reasons applied the
rich will still take out debt for one
reason and that reason is inflation over
the past year for everyday americans
inflation has been devastating given
rapidly rising everyday expenses but for
people who are in debt it's actually
rather beneficial here's the thing the
amount of money you owe is not going to
go up because of inflation but the
amount of money you earn will go up now
unfortunately wages don't always keep up
with inflation especially in times of
high inflation but while this strategy
works best if your income scales
perfectly with inflation it's also
applicable even if your income doesn't
quite keep up especially over the long
term for example a dollar today is only
worth half as much as a dollar from
1992. now let's assume that you got a
30-year fixed mortgage in 1992 for 200
000
at first maybe half of your net income
goes towards your mortgage payment after
30 years though let's say your income
doubles thanks to inflation and
promotions at this point the same
mortgage payment only accounts for a
quarter of your income and that's with
relatively conservative growth numbers
what if your income actually goes 5 or
10x in the next 30 years that mortgage
would become a municipal expense by the
time you pay it off and this is
especially applicable if you have a
business in a high growth area like many
billionaires it's not just billionaires
using the strategy either this is one of
the key strategies governments rely on
to reduce their debt load over the long
term they just inflate it away
now i would argue that governments have
taken this to an unacceptable extreme
but that's a whole other conversation
all you need to know is that making a
debt payment in the future should be
easier than it is right now so rich
individuals prefer to leverage this to
their advantage
hearing all these advantages it's likely
that many of you guys are wondering if
this strategy would work for you and
unfortunately if you have to ask that
question the answer is probably no
the best course of action for the
average person is to pay off student
loans car loans and credit card loans as
fast as possible or not take out these
loans in the first place there is one
area in which the average person could
deliver to strategy but it requires that
they're disciplined and willing to
invest regularly instead of taking out a
10 or 15-year mortgage it would be
smarter to take out a 30-year mortgage
and invest the monthly savings into the
s p 500 but if you know that you won't
be that disciplined and that you'll end
up spending this money instead of
investing it it's better to just get the
shorter mortgage and pay off the debt
and given that the average person falls
into this category sticking to dave
ramsey's advice is likely the best
course of action but that's why it makes
sense for billionaires to take out debt
instead of paying cash if you were a
billionaire would you still take out
debt comment that down below also drop a
like if this video gave you a new
perspective on debt and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one